♪ All, all the joys under the sun wrapped into one ♪
♪ You're all, all that I need ♪
(dramatic music)
(audience cheering)
Action!
CODA the film sparked the concept of this music video
where we can show the world how we as
deaf people experience music.
♪ You'll be there to push me up the hill ♪
♪ There's no, no looking back for us ♪
♪ We got love, sure enough that's enough ♪
♪ You're all, all that I need ♪
♪ to get by ♪
Music is so much more than sound.
It's feeling.
I love that smile.
The lyrical meaning of this song comes to life as a visual story.
From the rhythmic camera movements to dance-like blocking
that bring out the tone and mood of the music.
♪ You're all, all the joys under the sun wrapped into one ♪
♪ You're all, all that I need ♪
We have the opportunity to show added layers
that come from our specific experiences.
♪ All that I need ♪
♪ to get by ♪